bonsoir le 7-8 société tous les quinze
jours c'est ce qui fait débat dans la
société actuellement et ce qui fait
débat en ce moment ce sont les rythmes
scolaires alors un collectif de maires
frondeurs a été lancée à l'initiative du
maire ump d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous pour dire non aux changements
de rythmes scolaires c'est d'ailleurs un
sujet qui est au coeur des discussions
du congrès des maires qui se tient
actuellement à paris et avec mes invités
réunis ce soir sur le plateau en direct
on va essayer de comprendre ce qui ne va
pas dans la réforme et puis on va aussi
s'intéresser à ce qui va ou en tout cas
ce qu'ils avancent on parlera notamment
d'une expérience à la verrière alors mes
invités françois andré bonsoir
cpe en face de bertrand mesure bonsoir
co secrétaire départemental snuipp fsu
touma dire bonsoir j'aurais dû commencer
par vous les olé la courte à dire oui je
commence par vous tous mpt à dire le
cerveau est présente départemental de
l'apep 78 des parents d'élèves et des
enseignants en plateau alors d'abord un
petit rappel sur la mise en place de la
réforme scolaire dans le département il
ya 262 communes et huit seulement ont
choisi de changer de rythme scolaire dès
la rentrée 2013 alors un premier tour de
table si vous voulez bien on va
commencer par vous tous va dire cette
réforme scolaire alors vous en dites
quoi vous êtes pour vous êtes contre
elle est mal elle a mal démarré oui elle
a très mal démarré c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
être pour ou contre c'est vraiment une
vision un peu trop manichéenne de la
chose mais on peut dire que dans la
façon dont elle est mise en place et les
choix de travail qui ont été faits oui
nous sommes contre
la trop mesures pour la fsu vous étiez
finalement assez pour en dix ans la
semaine des 4 jours ce qui se fait et
c'est plutôt pas mal l'idée d'un jour
est tout à fait on s'en sortait de 10 de
casse du service public et en
particulier on avait eu cette réforme du
rythme scolaire on était passé à 4 jours
comme ça du jour au lendemain sans
aucune concertation
lorsque j'étais venu en plateau avant
les élections présidentielles vous
souvenez j'avais dit que ce qu'on
souhaitait avant tout c'est de la
concertation et être écouté et prendre
le temps d'inscrire les choses dans la
durée et avec le plus grand consensus
possible force est de constater que les
choses ont été précipitées et on est
loin du consensus d'ailleurs hier soir
lundi soir en c2 n ya une présentation
d'une motion
oui tout à fait qu'ils demandent en fait
à ce que le décret soit réécrit tout
simplement que les choses telles
qu'elles ont été posées ne sont pas
satisfaisantes elles ont besoin d'être
repensé réécrite et de permettre ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est le
dialogue la concertation et autant que
possible de dégager un consensus partout
là où il est possible c'est déjà un
consensus ça veut dire aussi faire des
aménagements une quels types
d'aménagements vous souhaiteriez vous
écoutez je crois que le la question qui
est du retour à quatre jours et demi et
d'une semaine de scolaires allergies
allégée en termes d'heures et tué
quelque chose qui fait consensus
maintenant là
la façon dont ça s'est organisé cette
année et surtout la façon dont ça a été
présenté ses terres qu on a essayé de
faire croire que la mise en place de
quelques activités ou de quelques
ateliers à l'issue de la journée pour
être le moyen de pallier aux difficultés
que l'école rencontre depuis depuis bien
longtemps bah non c'est pas c'est pas ça
ce n'est pas quelques tours de manège
qui permettent d'améliorer le sort des
écoliers français ça aurait pu être
l'occasion de relancer par exemple
l'éducation populaire de faire des
choses qui tiennent debout et quand on
regarde ce qui s'est mis en place dans
les communes à certains endroits il ya
une ambition il ya un souffle qui se
heurte à la réalité organisationnelle
mais à d'autres endroits on est très
loin d'une ambition et d'un souffle pour
l'accès pe alors cette réforme des
quatre jours c'était aussi n'était pas
finalement pour la semaine et quatre
jours elle part pour la semaine des 4
jours vous mais ce n'était pas favorable
à cette semaine des quatre jours plutôt
favorable était farouchement opposé à la
semaine des quatre jours qui avait été
effectivement brutalement mise en place
par xavier darcos mais c'était c'était
pour nécessiter de suppressions de
postes c'était c'était quand même une
des nombreuses mesures puisque chaque
année chaque ministre de l'éducation
nationale devait imaginer puisqu'il y
avait d'abord xavier darcos et puis
l'équipe chatel devait imaginer où
trouver 15000 postes et une année est
sorti du chapeau la semaine de quatre
jours parce qu'elle permettait de
reporter du temps d'enseignement sûr du
soutien scolaire sont sûrs de l'aide
personnalisée et donc de deux cas c'est
en fait les rased et de puiser dans les
rased un certain nombre de milliers de
postes donc elle est arrivée par hasard
enfin par hasard elle est arrivée parce
qu'ils avaient un programme politique de
non remplacement d'un instituteur sur
deux partout en occident a parlé donc en
suit alors la cellulose est 2009 a été
contre on sait mais la fcpe travaillé
réfléchi sur les rythmes de l'enfant
depuis 25 ans elle n'a jamais caché
qu'elle n'était pas favorable aux
rythmes de l'école actuelle à son rythme
de vacances scolaires et au rythme de la
journée de l'enfant depuis de nombreuses
années nous avons un projet éducatif que
nous avons remis en chantier donc on
prend on prend par surprise personne ça
fait partie de notre projet éducatif on
en accepte les malheurs du coup cette
réforme les quatre jours et demi alors
alors
elle est alors c'est une c'est un peu
calamiteux à cause du calendrier il faut
quand même reconnaître que c'est mal
joué c'est mal joué d'imposer aux
communes enfin de d'essayer de la mettre
en place en plein dans un contexte
d'élections
pour moi elle n'est pas précipiter parce
qu'il ya quand même deux ans il ya eu
deux ans de discussions le gouvernement
actuel est arrivé en 2012 nos
organisations ont signé l'appel de
bobigny qui est quand même un texte très
complet très riche qui donne une qui
donne une ligne pour la réforme donc on
ne peut pas dire s'est précipité les
gens savaient à peu près à quoi ce qu'on
a ce qu'il fallait mettre en oeuvre mais
effectivement le calendrier politique
est vraiment pas favorables en plus
d'autres d'autres calendriers nationaux
non le contenu du décret n'est pas
génial il faut quand même reconnaître
que
tout le monde et tout le monde avait de
l'ambition il fallait il faut sortir du
système actuel c'était un constat
partagé on a un système éducatif qui a
qui connaît qui connaît un peu une sorte
de dépression c'est à dire de dépression
de résultats
d'accumulation d'échec scolaire donc
tout le monde devait se poser la
question sur les sur les méthodes sur
les pistes à suivre pour redresser
maintenant
nous on considère qu'il faut y aller
c'est à dire que le décret probablement
il souffre comme toujours dans les
grands projets comme celui là parce que
c'est une réforme de société le diable
se cache dans les détails les gens qui
est autour de vincent peillon ont
négocié avec les partenaires éducatifs
ont dû oublier
pas mal de détails par exemple la
différence entre la maternelle et
l'élémentaire
voilà bien sûr je le dis entre
guillemets donc effectivement sur des
solutions la maternelle également
premier mini est en train de revenir
avec s'entretenir 2 et voilà comme quoi
on peut faire progresser un décret fur
et à mesure des protestations aussi donc
je pense qu'on va arriver à quelque
chose qui qui va déboucher mais il faut
pas retarder à chaque fois on veut un
report le report c'est souvent
l'annulation c'est souvent le gain de
temps qui permet de tenir et de ne pas
réformer nous souhaitons nous nous
souhaitons le maintien de cette réforme
nous en au décret s'il le faut mais en
tout cas sur le principe de réformer la
semaine de l'enfance et c'est pour nous
un incontournable et toi dire il sert
alors là il faut des aménagements mais
peut-être attention à tous les
aménagements qu'on fait parce qu'on
voulait vraiment faire sourire je pense
que la position de mon collègue n'est
pas très confortable parce que ben il va
dire qu'il est pour mais au fond ils
sont pas tellement pour et puis même
quand la réforme a été présentée aux
confins au conseil supérieur de
l'éducation appellent à voter contre la
fcpe qui pour ces justes abstenus donc
en fait ce qui est inquiétant d'ailleurs
et c'est le cas pour pour nos parents on
le constate pour plusieurs gouvernements
c'est le sentiment que il y a des choses
auxquelles un peu de bon sens où nos
parents qui ne sont pas des techniciens
évidemment notre mission est
certainement beaucoup plus facile enfin
je ne doute pas de la complexité de la
chose mais en même temps il ya des
choses qui sont tellement évidentes
qu'on ne comprend pas comment à un
niveau aussi haut on a pu ne pas y
penser mais c'est quoi par exemple c'est
bien par exemple 120 enfants de
maternelle et un enfant de l'élémentaire
quand mon collègue parle de réforme de
société c'est bien là le problème on
nous parle de réforme de rythmes de
l'enfant et en fait la seule chose qu'on
fait c'est qu'on réforme l'école mais
par des petites mesurettes monsieur
mesure vous parliez de la nécessité de
revenir à quatre semaines et demie
évidemment à quatre jours et demi
d'école évidemment pour ce il est tout à
fait logique que plus on a deux jours
d'école mieux c'est sauf qu'il y avait
d'autres pistes qui elles n'ont pas du
tout été exploré parce que d'autres
intérêts donc dans le rallongement
vrai calendrier annuel qui respecterait
le rythme de l'enfant un rythme qui fait
réellement consensus parce que
l'histoire de quatre semaines quatre
jours et demi une jours de pause une
journée de pause j'ai beaucoup d'amis
enseignants à la fcpe par la fcpe dans
des syndicats hors syndicats qui ne sont
pas tous unanimement convaincue qu'une
semaine d'enseignement continue soit une
bonne chose pour un ajustement vous êtes
plus tôt mercredi matin samedi matin
parce que se tenir toujours
samedi matin comme toujours dit on a
fait des sondages on demande aux parents
ce qu'ils pensent on y sème et nous par
exemple le douaron dans les deux langues
pour lui le mercredi matin et le samedi
matin
personnellement j'ai du coup samedi
matin c'est pas continuer pense que
c'est très compliqué oui je pense que le
samedi matin c'est pas continuer ça
permettrait peut-être davantage
d'accorder ces quatre journées et demie
d'enseignement tout en permettant aux
enfants qui en ont besoin de se reposer
le mercredi avec toutefois une réserve
qui n'est pas négligeable c'est qu'elles
sont les enfants qui se reposent
réellement le mercredi
quels sont ils ce sont ceux qui ont un
parent qui est à la maison tranquille y
ont des parents qui gagnent suffisamment
bien leur vie pour leur offrir une
solution de garde autre qu'un centre de
loisirs où ils partent parfois plutôt
qu'une journée d'école etc des
témoignages de parents dont les enfants
fréquentent le centre de loisirs qui
nous disent que la journée de leur
enfant est plus longue finalement le
mercredi que la journée d'école en tout
cas enfin la journée scolaire plus plus
les garderies donc ça c'était déjà une
évidence ensemble découvrir que pour
proposer des activités aux enfants il
faut des locaux on semble découvrir que
pour proposer des activités aux enfants
il faut des encadrants du court
effectivement même si on dit qu'on
revient pas dessus on a dès le début
vous rendez compte qu'on a fait une
réforme pour raccourcir la journée de
l'enfant elle était même pas encore en
application qu'on proposait comme
dérogation de faire des journées de six
heures deux fois par semaine c'est à
dire exactement la journée actuelle pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore changé de
rythme concevoir aisément que les
parents la dame sait plus du tout la
logique parce que en plus non seulement
ça c'est une contradiction ce qui est
avancé mais en plus ça suppose que du
coup les enfants ont une journée comme
précédemment que la au total vous êtes
d'accord pour la réécriture d'un décret
ce que propose des sujets l'impression
au monde
un décret moi ce que je lui trouve de
fondamente
oui oui si on tue tout est frais mais la
réécriture du décret s'impose pourquoi
parce que déjà ce qui à notre sens
aurait dû permettre quand même d'assurer
un minimum de sérénité c'est que on
aurait dû créer un cadre général
relativement contraignant et laisser
l'opportunité de faire quelques
dérogations en fonction des endroits on
parlait aussi tout à l'heure de l'âge
des enfants serait qu'un enfant de trois
ans n'est pas un enfant de 11 ou 12 ans
donc par définition il y avait nécessité
de faire des choses comme ça
force est de constater que c'est
l'exception qui devient la règle
on a quand même on trouve ici ou là des
choses assez baroque assez exotique à la
fois dans l'organisation dans les
horaires et tout ça apporte beaucoup
plus de désorganisation que ça n'apporte
vraiment d'amélioration
par exemple sur certaines journées de
classe quand vous enlevez un quart
d'heure vingt minutes sur une journée de
classe et que vous n'avez pas modifier
les programmes sachant que ses
programmes depuis ces dix dernières
années ce sont comment dire elle est
allongée du fait de on a rajouté le b2i
on a rajouté l'éducation par exemple
à la sécurité routière enfin toute une
série de choses qui se sont rajoutés qui
ont trouvé un cadre que l'on trouve mal
ficelé dans les programmes de 2008 qui
déjà était très difficile à réaliser
dans le cadre des quatre jours des 24
heures très masse et là on se retrouve à
refaire repenser une autre organisation
ça ne fonctionne par peut-être qu'on
aurait pu aussi s'interroger sur les
contenants avant de parler du contenu on
aurait pu parler de l'organisation
générale de l'école vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure l'année scolaire
on reste là aussi sur l'idée qu' il faut
24 heures x 36 semaines on reste sur des
choses comme ça alors que les études
internationales ne démontre absolument
pas que le nombre d'heures français
soient plus favorables à la réussite des
élèves que celui qui est pratiqué dans
d'autres pays tout cela n'a pas été
questionné tout ça n'a pas été interrogé
on nous a parlé un peu
on nous a parlé de re fondation va
refondation c'est pas un terme il s'agit
pas de changer quelques bricoles à la
marge j'ajouterai que là aussi on s'est
aperçu que diminuer le temps scolaire
des élèves savez forcément une incidence
sur la capacité des communes à pouvoir
accompagner cette diminution par
l'accueil des élèves au delà du temps
scolaire
il faut pas être grand clerc pour pau
pour s'en apercevoir auparavant donc
tout ça aurait eu besoin d'être d'être
réfléchi on a parlé d'un fonds
d'amorçage qui a eu beaucoup de mails
mal à se mettre en place d'ailleurs
parce que la caf n'était pas si
vaillante que ça à financer ce type
d'élément on sait pas trop ce que ça va
devenir enfin tout ça descende ya
tellement qu une réflexion beaucoup plus
profonde on va aller maintenant la
rencontre des habitants parce qu'on est
allé évidemment dans les rues de saint
quentin pour demander aux gens leur avis
sur la réforme des rythmes scolaires en
soit si ce qu'on ne sommes pas allés à
trappes justement puisque trappe c'est
une des communes où on pratique la
semaine des quatre jours et demi on est
allé dans d'autres communes pour
demander l'avis aux habitants c'est une
réforme qui n'a pas été pensé à la base
on n'a pas mis sur table toutes les
données avant et maintenant on se trouve
confronté à des gros problèmes de
structure est pour moi le l'enfant n'est
encore pas au coeur du problème l'enfant
n'a pas à continuer l'école jusqu'à
16h30 ça ne lui réduit pas son temps de
d'école de toute façon puisqu'il reste
est laid il est pas enfants alors qu'on
voudrait qu'il soit enfant qu'ils
puissent s'amuser avec les autres j'ai
ma soeur que sa fille qui a 9 ans et
elle est dégoûté parce que sa fille est
fatigué tout le temps que le mercredi
est passé leur temps ensemble à s'amuser
puisque maintenant il faut travailler
les activités ça va pas du tout c'est un
peu du n'importe quoi donc non je sais
pas trop court pour moi je suis contre
les ré les nouveaux rythmes scolaires
parce que les enfants n'ont plus l'eau
mercredi matin pour se reposer donc ça
les oblige le mardi avoir le même rythme
que dans la semaine et s'ils ont des
activités à faire l'après midi ça fait
que le mercredi est une journée pleine
en plus les activités proposées en fin
d'après midi ne sont pas toujours à la
hauteur de ce qu'on souhaiterait donc
c'est une fatigue qui est égal à ce
qu'il y avait avant donc moi
personnellement je suis contre moi je ne
suis pas du tout pour je trouve que
c'est compliqué pour les enfants de
tenir toute la semaine
je trouve très bien c'est les deux jours
actuels avec une coupure d'une journée
et deux jours ensuite comme ça ça me
paraît très très bien autrement ça fera
beaucoup trop long pour les enfants et
je pense que le gouvernement n'a pas les
moyens de mettre les éducateurs
suffisant et le matériel suffisant pour
occuper tel qu'ils l'ont prévu les
enfants l'après midi
voilà alors on a plaidé à vie contre
on vous dit rien sur les salaires alors
il ya eu j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
voisins-le-bretonneux il y avait du
monty neal broten est en tout cas pas
les gens parlent de culte dans des
villes où ce n'est pas encore en
application que je veux pas très bien
quelle est leur expérience personnelle à
baril au sein d'une amie on parle de
fatigue des enfants est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous est remontée aux
oreilles la fatigue des en coûtait
fatigue des enfants je sais pas si on
peut parler de fatigue des enfants est
lié les choses comme ça ce qui est
certain c'est que là où ça s'est mis en
place la difficulté d'organisation la
difficulté du montage fait que toutes
les communes où ça s'est mis en place
ont connu une désorganisation des écoles
en début d'année et ça c'est toujours
préjudiciable à la mobilisation de
l'ensemble assez peut-être pas la
réforme en elle même qui pourrait me je
suis fier c'est aussi la taillerie
groupe a des enfants facile à dire comme
ça ce qui est sûr c'est que des enfants
qui se retrouvent désorientés bon on a
eu des exemples assez caricaturaux comme
par exemple des écoles ou les horaires
été modifiée mais pas ceux de la
sonnerie vous imaginez ce que ça venait
dans une journée de classe où les
enfants ne savent pas et tout ça
manifeste quand même de d'éléments kitty
qui avait besoin d'être réfléchi moi je
pense que l'école c'est quelque chose
qui appartient à l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative et qu' il faut
mettre l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative autour de la table que chacun
vienne avec sa compétence qui lui est
propre c'est à dire les enseignants avec
la leur les parents avec la leur les
collectivités territoriales qui avec
celles qui leur sont propres et que
chacun réfléchisse de son point de vue
et essaye de dégager à la recension la
france si vous me permettez personne
n'est propriétaire de l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général c'est quelque chose
qui se construit à partir du moment où
on met les personnes en position d'être
acteur dans la définition de cet
internet et malheureusement
la façon dont les choses se sont passées
à fait d'accord n'ont pas permis de le
faire à daisy non on le voit bien à
travers ses reportages
l'intérêt général quand vous interviewer
les gens c'est d'abord l'intérêt de leur
emploi du temps à eux de leur emploi du
temps familial c'est leur intérêt
d'adultes c'est pas l'intérêt de
l'enfant qui prime dans dans ses
interrogations donc moi je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut savoir aussi se
fier à des des expertises fin c'est
cette question des rythmes dure encore
une fois depuis une vingtaine d'années
elle et elle est là elle est au coeur
d'un grand nombre de travaux de
sociologues et de chronobiologistes le
rapport de l'académie de médecine est
très nette il est très nette et le
l'appel de bobigny a été construit sur
ce en partie sur ce rapport donc il faut
aussi savoir faire un peu confiance aux
experts pour dire voilà il faudrait
réformer ce système parce que on vit sur
le sur un système hérité du passé qui
n'est pas forcément adapté aujourd'hui
à la halle au niveau d'éducation qu'on
demande aussi aux enfants de faire
confiance aux experts et bien être des
enfants c'est vrai que ces gens blackurn
la lumière d'agression sans fin
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
parce que d'abord les experts leur avis
peuvent peuvent varier les experts qui
sont reconnus un moment dans un pays un
instant donné sont pas ceux qui sont
reconnus ailleurs il faut qu il ya qu à
regarder tout ce qui se passe autour du
numérique on passe d'un extrême à
l'autre
par rapport à une vision enfin à la pub
on essaye si vous voulez d'éviter un peu
les dogues ça c'est mieux ça c'est pas
mieux pour la simple et unique raison
comme vous le disiez à juste titre il y
à un seul rapport sérieux effectivement
les rythmes scolaires je crois que les
premiers travaux qui ont été faits au
tour que nous nous avons retrouvé dans
les archives de la peine quand on
traiter les dossiers pour présenter des
rapports date de 1957 donc c'est dire
que la question s'était posée depuis
longtemps d'accord je ne suis peut-être
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur
la nécessité de réunir tout le monde
pour réfléchir à ce qu'il faut faire tu
qui a ulcéré flexion je dirais plutôt
qu'il fallait écouter ce qui a été dit
parce que le consensus était
effectivement autour de la nécessité de
réorganiser l'année scolaire moment va
pas y revenir ce qui est des
chronobiologistes moi je reste toujours
un peu un peu réservés parce que le seul
un rapport qui existe vous me corrigez
je ne suis pas enseignante comme en tout
cas non nous avons trouvé de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale qui fait une étude de toutes
les deux tous les calendriers
dérogatoire parce qu'il ya eu des
expérimentations depuis quelques années
finalement ne conclue à rien conclut
rien voilà lorsque je vais je voudrais
juste vous interrompt pendant l instant
parce qu'on a beaucoup on a parlé de la
concertation la nécessaire concertation
je voudrais qu'on aille du côté de la
verrière puisque la verrière a organisé
une vingtaine de réunions de
concertation et que samedi dernier ils
ont justement présenter leur planning de
rentrée pour 2014 c'est dire s'ils sont
quand même en avance puisque
l'inspection académique souhaite que les
mairies présente un pré projet d'ici la
fin du mois de décembre donc on va voir
comment ça se passe du côté de la
verrière
les rythmes scolaires font râler dans
certaines villes d'autres par contre
s'organise semble-t-il plus
tranquillement à la verrière voici à
quoi ressemblera la vie scolaire des
enfants à la rentrée 2014 ils
travailleront le mercredi matin
concernant le planning on est plutôt
rassuré son cache pas qu on était super
inquiète fait partie des enseignants qui
ont fait la grève on a fermé notre école
jeudi dernier
sans connaître en fait tous les détails
concernant l'élémentaire on est plutôt
rassuré une réunion de présentation
s'est tenue ce samedi l'aboutissement
d'une vingtaine de réunions de
concertation avec les parents et les
enseignants où finalement tout le monde
a fait un pas vers l'autre
nous avions préconisé préconisé nous en
tant que parents d'élèves des activités
plus tôt en début d'après midi
maintenant on
on comprend aussi que si on veut des
activités de qualité
1h30 c'était c'est mieux pour avoir ses
activités et donc donc une réunion en
début d'après midi ça devenait un petit
peu compliqué donc effectivement le
basculement deuxième partie d'après-midi
nous on a fait deux choix forts premier
choix de travailler sur la pause
méridienne en l'élargissant un peu et en
lui donnant un peu plus de contenu pour
faciliter le travail des enseignants
deuxièmement un choix de faire d'étape
des temps d'activités périscolaires pour
les enfants d'âge élémentaires d'une
heure trente pour avoir la qualité au
rendez vous cette qualité a un prix il
va falloir recruter des animateurs
adapter les locaux scolaires la ville de
la verrière a estimé le coût de la
réforme à 150000 euros dont la moitié
soutenu par l'état et la caisse
d'allocations familiales dans son
travail la commune compte s'appuyer sur
les associations locales la ligue de
l'enseignement a joué le rôle
d'accompagnateur
on va accompagner la commune sur la une
réflexion de fond
et la formation aussi du personnel sur
la pause méridienne parce que c'est un
enjeu très important dans les yvelines
parmi les 262 communes du département 8
ont fait le choix de changer de rythme
scolaire à la rentrée de septembre 2013
les autres communes ont jusqu'à la fin
du mois de décembre pour présenter leur
premier projet
voici l'exemple à la verrière il nous
reste une petite minute et pour conclure
ce débat juste un rappeur todo
d'habillement d'une action rapide
quelles actions à venir quelle
mobilisation pour vous
nous l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que les choses puissent se se dérouler
dans les meilleures conditions pour pour
l'école
donc le chantier est vaste et ben on est
en attente de décision et de
désorientation que ministre donnera
thomas hier sur le terrain à chaque fois
qu'il ya une concertation qui le
proposaient nous accompagnons parce que
tant que le décret n'est pas retirée
n'est pas suspendu même si voilà on
l'espère puisque le gouvernement était
capable de le faire pour autre chose
donc on aimerait bien que dans l'intérêt
des élèves il puisse faire la même chose
surtout que ça ne coûtera rien à l'état
si on suspend ce décret comprend le
temps de la réflexion ça ne coûterait
rien donc ça pourrait être une bonne
idée si ça n'était pas le cas nous
accompagnons parce que nous estimons
qu'il faut que les parents participent
autant que faire se peut pour limiter
les dégâts je puis dire france andré on
n'a pas tout se joue à la rentrée 2014
parce qu'il faut quand même rappeler
qu'il ya seulement 20 % des élèves en
france qui sont sous le nouveau régime
dont il ya encore 80% qui se préparaient
à y passer c'est pour ça que quand on
dit que les enfants sont fatigués alors
que en gros on a six semaines
d'application pour seulement 20 %
d'entre eux on peut quand même pas tirer
des conclusions hâtives moi je trouve ce
qui est important c'est d'accompagner
une rentrée 2014 réussi est l'un des
bénéfices de cette réforme c'est de
finalement faire travailler ensemble des
communautés qui n'avaient pas l'habitude
de le faire et qui se dit et qui devrait
participer justement un vrai projet de
société une réforme de sa saison et on a
vu l'exemple de la verrière les réunions
de concertation ont finalement abouti en
tout cas un accord entre des gens qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude de travailler
entre eux comme comme vous l'avez dit ce
sera donc le 11 décembre nous l'avait
dit que les mairies devront présenter
leur projet à l'inspection académique
merci beaucoup à vous trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat société autour des
rythmes scolaires bonne soirée à vous